hello went to welcome to this video
playing carrom ass off here with white
yeah got a very bad school again sir but
I could get a win in yesterday if I
remember correctly in one of the live
streams okay he's going for the stone
wall against the Reggie which is this is
close to unplayable for black we'll see
what happens but usually black guys in
turn into big problems here so we'll see
him oh my god the queen bee three is the
best move with I remember and remember
correctly and the problem is he cannot
recapture sb7 is hanging so he will just
lose this pawn it's still a reasonably
murky but from an objective point of
view and black is in deep deep trouble
here okay I'm just going to keep it like
that we very difficult for him to now
regain the pawn so um Bishop g5 is
interesting orbis should be 3 i'm not
sure about it i mean you can never go
age 6 this is why this is kind of
attractive
so it's not entirely clear if this pin
is doing all that much okay he's gotten
rid of the pin I could try to just
double on the D file there are many
pieces on the D file so this could be an
ID em like that okay so how to continue
from here i wonder if i should actually
play with g4 and keep the corn like that
too that my knight can actually return
to the game h3 it looks useful anyway so
I'm going for it
yeah so this is the thing do I go G for
you or not yes night takes g4 maybe
which looks a little bit of putting so
maybe we should actually get rid of this
especially three not not quite clear I
can also just trade stuff okay it's not
entirely clear to me I mean I've got
this porn but as long as there are that
many pieces on the board I cannot easily
converted Knight f3 comes into
consideration here or maybe this one I
think the bishop is not actually doing
all that good down Knight f3 now IM
going back for you for doesn't really do
doesn't really help him right i have 93
or 95 93 and 94 I mean I'm sorry
and the night on h4 has done a good job
of keeping the porn for for a while but
it has to be back in the game cannot
stick on edge for all the time
again I'm ready for g4 let's just keep
this pawn question is what about g5
actually can I use this for an attack
that that seems quite feasible actually
and now I definitely will go g5 without
night h5 being possible and now nighty
nighty for looks logical there's also f6
because you cannot capture it yeah so I
should do it right if you cannot take
this pawn that must be should be quite
good you can move the night down has to
cover at 7i guess somehow okay so Queen
g6 it's probably Queen to have 794 looks
normal here but this Bishop to f5 but
then i can go connect when you too now
it's not bad let's do it I shouldn't get
into into any huge time issues here
oh ok ok let's go here take age 5 I
don't think he wants to go I think he
didn't want wanted to go there Abbott
maybe he had no alternative anymore
giving me that protected pass on the F
and file cannot be ideal ok i was
preparing bishop age three and turn it
one more prep move for that so what
about bishop to have five here is that
is that something that is the
threatening something probably not but
this is actually threatening night takes
h5 check
okay so what's going on here I take
their queen takes about this this I have
to do anyway so let's do it and now he
will have knight Knight f3 somehow
coming it's okay currently he can't
still cannot take I think time morning I
did actually threaten screens you form
it's a little bit annoying here okay so
this is a chick I don't really know my
time is running low check maybe just
route h8 or some some stuff here that's
possible I'm getting this is getting
confusing but it's not clear that you
threatens all that much if i take c 593
ok jus i can actually take on f3 i think
so if you have some made now or the
power to him cannot check really say
much about this Queen to e7 check check
check check check
black resigns I don't know maybe he had
something because I because I somehow
allowed counterplay don't know okay so
yeah as I said this opening is extremely
questionable especially in that form I
mean the stone wall in itself is
questionable against a Nandi for but in
this form it says its border line
playable yeah queen bee three sm is even
stronger than then other moves because
it has a dual threat ef5 and c5 the
relatively best now is Queen to be six
after which Quincy tomb is pretty strong
but yea he is in deep trouble him so he
have his upon down and he's got
absolutely no compensation for it the
main issue besides being a pawn down
that this is extremely limiting a black
doesn't have squares here like this for
example so this position is more or less
a win why this is doing a good job and I
feel I did a decent job form quite a
long time yeah I've kept my molasses in
G form yet after that it should it
should be winning I'm happy up to this
point here but probably I'm letting
something slip here yeah just taking one
g7 is strong yeah why not I mean this
this looks entirely unplayable okay this
is also probably not bad yeah this is a
very strong asset but I somehow couldn't
finish it off so up to hear all this
looks nice okay the engine actually
gives this with like plus a million okay
this is kind of nice and threatens
Bishop g6 King takes Queen h5 maid gets
even stronger check no things got got
slightly
irritating maybe to the point that i had
problems decided I hear he's got a draw
he's got to draw 9h form a narrow gauge
one still wins very clearly engine
engine wise at least like plus 4 and TM
after that i'm winning again yet that's
the drawer probably because i cannot go
here check I have to do this and then
you can check me again and well I have
to repeat and here she I'm winning again
which I couldn't really figure out
during the game it felt quite scary but
I can take him this is a double check
and here he really has a no good move
I'm threatening made myself so it's it's
a check check check only and tears are
running out of checks i can just escape
i have three jack and yeah here can
check king of three years checkmate and
next move hey okay okay that's very
cold-blooded shack if you have no time
you can tend to go for a checks this is
what what i did here now I'm getting the
Queen back and I'm not under any threats
myself yeah okay I am allowed a big
scare there but other than that the game
was nothing quite ok alright thanks for
watching